i
without a gun
yeah how tall do you think he is
short yeah yeah well uh first of all
folks we have brandon shop today
uh uh uh ufc uh i i watch you come up
bro from freaking ultimate fighter
coming in
uh uh your fight against crow cop who
crow cop back in the days was like
god to a bunch of people him and fedor
like that's the era
we watch right those two guys you win
against crocodiles
yeah so uh and then comedy and then
rogan and then you guys got your own
show with you and uh theo and brian
cowan ryan which brian callum funny
story one time i go to show a cavalia
and burbank so it's me and jen this is
2010. yeah we go to cavalia i turn
around i'm like
i recognize this guy's face i said
brother why do you look so familiar
mm-hmm so you know his personality like
all over the place he freaking all
everybody loves this guy right i said
you
you know
you guys you know
in every movie but you just don't
remember yeah but from the hangover he
was you don't remember
extremely charismatic charming guy
non-stop energy but anyways it's great
to have you here i'm glad we have it
thank you yeah a big fan man yeah
appreciate you so you were saying sammy
right you were talking about yeah i had
a question for you guys because again
brian's a big fan all that mafia stuff
he won't shut up about it and he's
talking about how tough they are and i
propose the question are they actually
tough like tough like i guess what's
your definition of tough
well tough is if you do a street fight
one-on-one i mean it's not it's not even
a that's not the world
so you're not dealing with that kind of
tough
um
the tough of their world is
the amount of influence they had
and who they had in their pockets
and how much business they controlled
but you're talking power right that's
powers
very different of course it is it's very
different you know if you want to go
into a uh they're tough to go against
yeah like
like the union but i'm gonna tell you
this so sammy's sitting here adam's
sitting here okay
the entire time adam he's 6-1 adam's an
athlete adam was a he called me skinny
but whatever
he's got six more but i think we need to
find the term athlete as well
you guys are very loose with these by
the way
description athlete tough
[Laughter]
the guy that's actually could be an
athlete these two guys play so him he's
the best uh they call him the best
jewish athlete out of miami i don't know
what that means but being like the
tallest [ __ ] that's kind of what they
think of this guy it's like winning gold
in the special exactly that's me right
here yeah yeah pretty scary so we go to
dinner with sammy and then we do a
podcast and adam decides to ask a
question from sammy uh what'd you say so
you've been around the block for a while
yeah yeah but let's use your knowledge
of history to our advantage here because
whoa you [ __ ] call me old yeah what
are you like but how old is he he's 17.
mid 70's we're doing that yeah yeah yeah
i'm like dude i'm not asking you
yeah exactly you know what i will tell
you so i haven't interviewed a lot of
them there was one guy frank collada i
don't know if you've seen the movie
casino if you've seen the movie casino
franken
yeah he wasn't so frank colada is
do you know in the scene casino where
they go and he puts a guy's head in a
vice versa
he's like that's the name that's who
you're saving yeah that frank colada i
interviewed when he walked into the room
it's
cold as ice you felt his spirit
capable capable not like this but cable
like this capable in many different ways
doesn't make it tough but here's the
thing though that makes you a sociopath
but let me ask you though that's like
saying like a wide receiver is tough
because they're not going to beat up a
offensive lineman and uh you know heinz
ward was yeah but i'm just saying
there's there's different spots on the
team everybody has a role to play but
but there's some receivers that put it
on you man then there's no matter what
so let me ask you guys you played in the
nfl yeah okay
again we're loose with the turn down the
nfl i just want to be very clear i had a
cappuccino with the buffalo bills and
then they're like we're all set on slow
white how good was that makes sense how
good was the cappuccino uh not good okay
very sour and short so so question
question if we if you if you measure
toughness you're talking sportsier
if you measure toughness what sport
would you say produces the toughest guys
this is four sports not even a question
hockey four sports nfl nhl mba go from
the toughest to the left nba's least the
least yeah
divas yeah because they're they're
pedigree like when they're like 13 you
know they're getting rainbows and chips
yeah they've been rich they're not
enough yeah yeah got it nfl and they're
all awesome
pretty tough nfl is pretty ahead of nhl
here's here's why nhl doesn't count
they're all white guys okay it's like
like what are you telling me they're
missing teeth though i mean i know but
they're on ice and they're in canada
that's all there is to it
and also it's not a worldwide you're
allowed to have a boxing match in the
middle of your fridge
you just you just said the nhl is not a
worldwide sport but the nfl and the nba
are no well nba is for sure
but half the people in the nhl got
nothing but consonants in their name
they all come from northern sweden
they've come from sweden
you're about to get a lot of nordic hate
there brendan oh no i don't want that
the point is they're all white you know
what i'm saying what do you mean by that
what do you mean when you say they're
all white it's tough because if you look
at basketball like it's a global sport
soccer's global sport fighting's a
global sport so you're getting the best
of the very best in nhl as soon as black
guys are like what the is this a pair of
skates they're [ __ ] all those european
and white guys are familiar i can't have
breaking news that's not happening
anytime soon well never say never okay
we'll see we'll see how that happens
you're saying there could be a major
search of uh uh if they want to go into
hockey yeah
you know those black guys skating out
there you know they're they're coming
for your nascar driver ranger's got
keandre miller and ryan reeves man here
we go there you go we're on on the way
to the cup obviously that logic the
range is already happening we've left
one sport out we've left one sport out
so it's basically nhl at the top where
you put nfl at the top
no i'll agree
nhl they're pretty [ __ ] tough okay
the amount of strain and then also their
schedule the work schedules the beast
okay so you put nhl nfl so now the
debate's between mlb and nba so who is
it
nbc's dead mlb is yeah mlb so you had a
good story you told yesterday about one
time when you hit this bomb that you hit
this homer in
yeah yeah uh
it was a brawl it was
i'm the only guy that ever got uh a
nine-game suspension for a home run that
didn't count i hit a home run it's a
long long story did you start brad isn't
it like frowned upon if you like flipped
the battery that's right
it's called entertainment you hate
tickets yeah well this is the thing it
was it was cub scout day at the stadium
so the the commissioner was pretty
pissed off that we started a 45 minute
brawl at no with nothing but 5 000 cub
stats that makes sense
in the stands so yeah basically what
happened was there was an old pitcher
named dwan brazilton he was a first
draft pick yeah he was a first round
draft pick he's from florida tough dude
and um you know he got he got a little
chatty with me i got a little chatty
back at him he threw a fastball wasn't
fast enough i enjoyed it a little bit
too long i guess and his catcher decided
to punch me in the face when i came
across home plate and then the bench is
cleared bench is cleared i was about to
get absolute i was about to get
absolutely destroyed the entire dugout
for them comes out ready to come and get
me as i'm tussling on the ground with
their catcher and i'm literally at this
point i've got them in hold and i'm
thinking like oh [ __ ] and then antonio
alfonseka google this dude is this all
like dominic interesting he was an
all-star in the big leagues he's down
here with us he's like six eight four
hundred pounds he's got six fingers on
both hands six toes el poopo ray and out
of nowhere this this angel this giant
dominican 400 pound angel comes swooping
in and tackles their entire team before
they get to him this guy saved your life
i owe everything i have to this day
gerard were you this antonio
no i was beautiful i was uh i was just
that'd be the biggest baseball player
that was 200 offensive guard 225 pounds
of beautiful did you play football too
or no yeah yeah yeah
yeah i played football so well they let
me play baseball makes sense
brandon when you played your cappuccino
with the bills what position were you
tied in okay
you had some wheels oh yeah yeah you had
some hands yeah i played university of
colorado before that and then yeah you
were buffalo yep and you're from
colorado right you're growing and
raising denver who were you in high
school what do you mean who were you in
high school if we're in high school
you're
16 17 years old who are you in high
school i was i think i was 6 270 pounds
so i was like a late bloomer and then i
was friends with you know there's jock
so i obviously played football so i was
a jock played football lacrosse but i
was friends with everybody i was the guy
had all the friends football and
lacrosse so you were tough with no
hand-eye coordination i don't know
yeah
did you play division
[Laughter]
who was there when you were was a jeremy
bloom there jeremy bloom yeah yeah
jeremy bloom lawrence vickers joel joe
klatt's the voice of fox now for uh
college football this is post cordelia
this is the cordelia cordell stewart's
in 94. rashaan salam cordell stewart
what a name slash yep so i've been to a
i lived in denver actually you used to
stand up but the comedy works oh yeah we
were just there at six great place and
the one thing that i remember out of
being at a colorado buffalo game it was
third down it would be a key play yeah
you would take out your keys the whole
[ __ ] stadium is just doing the little
key jingle did you catch the ball on
third down and third and 16 did you
catch it sometimes okay yeah we were
when i was there we were good gary
barnett days yeah we were good who was
the coach gary barnett yeah came from
northwestern it used to be a great
program i don't know what happened to
the program yeah great program yeah
dicey but bro living
what causes those programs to change you
get a program that is it the head coach
the head coach takes care of the
shooting boosters with them
and recruiting so gary barnett got in
trouble my senior year he got fired
after that because that though they cut
katie and ida the female kicker time out
there there's some issue with her and
you know sexual allegations with the
players so he got fired over that which
is insane
and then they went the complete opposite
way and then they hired this guy uh
hawkins who was from boise state soft
soyboy so he gets there and he recruits
like all these small white guys with
good grades
that's how you build a program that's
what that's what the sec
they've never come back from that just
to be clear brendan what is a soy boy
soy boy i've never heard this term no
get out of here yeah by the way his
nickname is soy boy i'm being serious
really that's what everybody runs the
soy boy mafia
oh wow be easy with your words here bro
yeah what is it in your opinion uh the
opposite of sam sammy the bowl
[Laughter]
that made sense the fact that you sat
across from not a killer yeah not a
killer no
the only thing heterosexual about adam
is that he likes women that's the that's
true you're not good you're not gay but
your boyfriend yeah there you go go back
to it though go back to though because
what what program has stayed relevant
for a long time freaking alabama
that was bad back in the day yeah
and they were bad
to me is like one of those schools like
it's famous for being famous they've
never won which one notre dame what have
they won they've won nothing they went
back in the day but yeah they were
famous haven't done anything since then
yeah like you know you know what what
are you talking about notre dame they're
famous for being famous what have they
done in 30 years in 30 years
they're famous for rudy and they're
they're always good though but then they
don't have a home right like because
they're they're independent so they're
never in a conference they'll have
championship games but then they're
always on tv they always get prime time
games exactly yeah yeah i wonder because
college you know you guys are changing
every four years so you may build a
legacy with a popovich and you got a tim
duncan and parker for like 15 years and
you can win back to back to back college
you got to like so does it really come
down to the coach i think it comes down
to the boosters the coach has comes
right down to recruiting recruiting
to your point you mentioned basketball
basketball is even tougher because those
those boys can play one year and go they
fail that's right nba yeah so it's
impossible if you're a basketball coach
so then does it come down to coaching
like you think about like kentucky you
know kentucky's got is that california
calipari does it come down to yeah
calipari and i were sitting and i'm
talking to you i'm like so how do you
recruit
what is the recruiting style did he say
money i mean that's a different guy sat
down with usc is mike garrett who was
their uh athletic director
and i'm saying it's like 15 years ago i
said so mike i'm trying to sell him a
policy and i was introduced to my one of
the guys anyway so i'm like so mike how
you doing he says let me tell you how
i'm doing he opens the door you see that
kid right there how tall is he i said
he's pretty tall i sat next to him he's
seven feet tall
and he's 16 years old and everybody in
america wants him here now watch who's
sitting next to him who's in the next
zone so you see you sitting next to him
that's his mom you know why she's here
she wants me to give her a million bucks
now what do i do
what do i do
so coach cal says no no no this is
garrett garrick was a heisman trophy
winner for usc years ago years ago who
becomes the athletic director for usc
this is the carol era this is the reggie
right this is that area yeah yeah that's
like an era by the way
before nios this is why i'm saying
boosters like you can't
john calipari can't go to that dude's
mother and give him a million dollars
but john calipari go to a friend of the
program patrick beth david and be like
you know what booster yeah you know what
his mom's an accountant great accountant
you need accountants don't you patrick
you've got a job open for two million
dollars don't you patrick and there's
nothing wrong with you hi you can hire
whoever you want to hire and as long as
that player goes to big state you that
mom gets that two million it's the it's
the movie blue chips
brandon going back to you so
you know you you watch the video when i
don't know if you've seen the video
where where dwayne johnson's sitting
down i think with wme or whoever he's
sitting down with and he says
you know i want to be the will smith
except bigger right here's what i want
to be and he gives this message he gives
us talk that i want to be this guy i
think it's even a message he's given to
the lakers one time in the locker room
it's a real good video to watch
and then you watch you know his playbook
maybe he came
and he took the hulk hogan route you
know how cogan was before before it was
like hulk hogan right he was the guy
and then you know he kind of takes that
angle the rock becomes what he becomes
and after his first fight he says i'm
not going to play the bad guy i'm always
going to be the good guy i don't want to
play the villain in the w he never
wanted to play the villain right and he
takes that route
what what route are you taking because i
i feel like there's a couple routes one
route is you come in
so you're an athlete obviously you're an
athlete i mean you're a qualified
athlete this is not no minor leagues or
you know you're talking about your
qualified athlete you had your
cappuccino nobody here had cappuccino
with the buffalo bills at least you made
it to that level right and then you go
ufc so
is there a route there where you were
thinking about you seem like a smart guy
you're not a guy that's like doing it
just to wing it no what was your what
route are you taking
god that's a good question um
i don't know if it's a route like none
of it's pre-planned but i i think
growing up and i deal what i wanted to
do
and then i was gifted athletically and
the neighborhood i grew up in in aurora
colorado was predominantly black so the
way to be
like to fit in was to be good at sports
i was like all right well this can get
me through so i don't get bullied and
stuff so
i gravitated towards sports because i
had a just a talent for it so that's how
i made friends through sports stuff like
that but my passion was like i'd watch
saturday night live with my mom so i
want to be like adam sandler but there
was but in denver and like there was no
like outlet for that so i was like i
guess and i do sports but i was the
funny guy in the locker and stuff like
that
and then got to the ufc
and then i just ran in the ufc like
if you had nate diaz sitting here connor
you know kane velasquez or francis ghana
and you ask them about fighting they
love it it's all they want to do i hated
it
i was just good at it really i [ __ ]
hate what you hate about it um it was
just so stressful i don't like to hurt
people like my coaches in training were
like man you got to go hard i'm like i
don't want to hurt a man and they're
like that you got to go hard and it's
just it's not my nature i'm not an
aggressive person i'm not a violent
person to me how did you get into the
sport got into fighting because i got
cut from the bills
and then i was this big athletic dude
and i always liked the ufc
now selling supplements door to door and
i need to stay in shape so i started to
do jiu jitsu and i signed up the first
day and they're like man you're pretty
good that's like really like yeah we
have a big guy because you need to go
with another big guy he'll be here
tomorrow he drives down from greeley
which is like two hours away he goes he
comes every tuesday thursday he'll be
good for you to train with and he he
needs a bigger guy train he's just
starting out too like right whatever so
he i get there the next day an hour
early and walk shane carwin and if you
know shane carl he's the ufc heavyweight
champion
tyler
we started together so what year is this
from
2007.
that's something a lot of people don't
know you just gave great insight into
the martial arts world is when you're a
bigger dude and you're fighting there's
so there's such a dearth of talent that
anybody that's in the heavyweight or
light heavyweight that you come up with
it's hard to spar with these dudes and
come up with them because you're gonna
end up fighting them oh yeah this is the
guy right here yeah
certified badass huh yeah ufc
heavyweight champion like one of the
hardest hitters of all time but then you
know he was older he was like 36 and i
was i was young man so i didn't have
money i was broke but he paid for all my
training just so i trained with him and
then now when you're training with him
is he peeking or is he a little bit past
peak uh he's peaking he is peeking
okay yeah i got my ass whipped so you're
an everyday perfect teacher for you
though right yeah so i learned so much
for him so then
he got into the ufc and then uh i was
training and again i'm selling
supplements door door and i'm making a
lot of money living with my brother and
then uh he goes hey golden gloves is
next week the big boxing tournament and
i was like
kind of boxing not really like i do it
to stay in shape and he's like i signed
you up for it i'm like what he's like i
signed you up you're doing it and i'm
corny i'm like dude i don't wanna do
golden gloves he's like just do it see
how you do
so i go there i remember telling my dad
because you know i have a double major
he's like dude use your degree my dad's
a businessman he's like he's your
[ __ ] degree yeah yeah i was like i'm
gonna try this fighting i want to get
kicked in the head yeah and then um he
was completely against i said all right
dad they signed me up for golden gloves
it's the biggest national boxing
tournament if i win that you'll i want
you to give me your blessing to continue
fighting if i lose i'll do whatever you
want i'll work for you you're talking to
pops talking pots okay got it so he
comes to this golden gloves term in
denver colorado and it's like pretty
hoody man i'm the only white kid it's
all mexican black kids and they're like
you're in the audience and your coach is
wrapping your hands i'm like what the
[ __ ] and then they give you your gloves
and it's from the previous fight so
they're bloody and sweaty not for me
anybody knows me i'm like a germaphobe i
was i was like the [ __ ] am i doing
but and then so
it was a nightmare nightmare and then oh
and then in boxing traditional boxing
amateur boxing can't have a beard so
they made me shave so i have this
mustache so everyone thinks i'm this big
mexican
so i go so i go up there and you know i
had six fights i won all the fights by
knockout really yeah so you came in
there and dominated
wow one day six fights one day three
three the first night three the next
night and then and then when i get to
the championship fight to wrap my hands
and i was fighting a guy who was 46-0 in
the army he won all his fights in armies
undefeated big black guy six seven and
he's walking i'll never forget he's
walking by to wrap my hands my dad's
there my dad you know my dad's not
familiar with the fight game he was
jesus christ
jesus christ who is he fighting
me and dad
you can't he goes you can't do this you
you shouldn't do this i go no let's see
how it goes and i knocked him out in the
second round and i knocked this dude out
yeah my dad was like maybe we can do it
how cool is that in front of that though
so you ended up winning the tournament
what what in the tournament yeah dude
yeah so you're like this like the
opposite of accidental champion we're
like i don't know dad i think
and then from there like the next month
they signed me up to for mma fight and
then i won that in 36 seconds and then i
had one more fight won that in a minute
and then i was training with like gsp
rashad evan shane carwin all these guys
and rashad goes hey you know the next
ultimate fighter is heavyweights okay
cool he goes you should uh do it and i
go i don't know if that's for me because
i still wasn't sure what i was going to
do and i get a call from them and
they're like hey we'd love for you to uh
come to the interviews so i skipped all
the tryouts everything because rashad
was like this is the guy so i go the
interviews and
i've always had like gift of the gab
like talk [ __ ] like i'm you know so i
get in there and just blow the interview
away and like yeah you're in who's the
interview who's interviewing you the
interview is the dana the ufc and then
all at the time it's on spikes so what
are they asking
just like how do you feel about this
well what if this guy does and then i
cause i've always i'm a smaller
heavyweight yeah and they go you could
when i remember when i walked in they go
you're too small you're too small no
we're good we're in they're [ __ ] how
different are you size wise than today
i'm 250 now it's probably 235 okay 15
pounds not a big difference not crazy
but they're like oh you're too small and
you're what six four
yeah they're wow you're too small we're
good but they're [ __ ] when they see
what i do i go too small i was like i
bet you i [ __ ] win this thing like
sit down and then i just started you
know giving them [ __ ] i was in the house
and then i remember all these like war
stories from guys like how tough it is
and how terrible is and to me i was like
hold on it's hold on it's six weeks you
give me any food i want that i want to
order any drink i want i just can't talk
to my family or friends i was like this
is a vacation this is like willy wonka's
chocolate factory not talk to family and
friends no but in fairness you're not
cutting weight though no yeah no no
communication with outdoor outside world
no magazines no tv you're 16 other dudes
in a house the only time you leave the
house is to train so they want animosity
and then they give you all the liquor
you want all the liquor
drunk and then just lippy great strategy
yeah but turn the air conditioning off
break the thermostat it's like the real
world mixed with actual real fighters
yeah and so my season which was the
biggest season of all time not because
of me because kimbo slice was on there
roy nelson
but i was in the house so for me
it was like be going through football
right like i walked down to uc colorado
earned a scholarship like to me the
grind i have always embraced that so i
was like oh i'm gonna be so much more
mentally tough than these guys so we're
in the hot tub and i forget this first
night we're in the hot tub and this big
black guy dominic rogers everyone's
scared of this guy and i remember we
were uh like sipping a beer or something
like that he was i didn't drink it all
in the house
at all the six weeks no
consciously or you just don't drink i
found a sign of weakness so i'd pick up
on things and look for wheat smart so he
was in the hot tub he goes man i just
want to win one and then the at least
get to the finale if you just win one
and when i hear him say if i just win
one i went i'm picking him so that next
morning i go to our head coach rashad
evans i said i want to fight d'amico
rogers first he goes dude that's their
number one that's a terrible idea i'm
[ __ ] telling you dude give me him
because he wasn't you thought he was
mentally weak yeah i thought he wanted
it yeah i thought he wanted to do do
those count as pro fights when you do
that
uh no they don't which is insane so you
don't get paid for that you get paid but
it's just whatever the ufc pays you no
[ __ ] it's not like sanctioned by the
commission even though the commission's
there but because it's two rounds
it doesn't get classified as a pro fight
but everybody's a pro in there and the
reason they do that because they don't
want the results getting out to the
public that's when the show airs crazy
destiny [ __ ] man you just wanted to stay
in shape so you thought like murder
hugging would be a fun little hobby to
get into so you picked that guy picked
that guy beat him and then was off to
the races and then they give me the
worst matchup possible it's john john
madison who's a four-time
all-american wrestler national champion
undefeated guy in the first round he's
just whooping my ass mopping the floor
and i'm like there's no way i go out
like i remember him on top me held me
there i'm like there's no way i go out
like this man and then the second round
came and i saw him getting tired like
yes
and then he was standing i was still
right hand boom knocked him out got him
made it to the semi-final against marcus
jones who was a former uh first round
draft pick in the nfl played for tampa
bay for a number of years
monster
and uh worst case scenario like do not
let him get on top of you we don't care
what happens don't let him get on top of
you and within 30 seconds he's on top of
me gets full mount he's raining elbows
down on me
somehow i get out of it and then we're
uh we're in the clinch and he's way
bigger than me and he takes my head and
just knees me right in the nose it's the
first time i've ever like broke my nose
i just remember like my nose is all the
way over here and then again there's
something in me going there's no way we
go out like this man and then just a
right hand boom knock them out and i'm
doing uh snow angels inside the middle
bro i have a question
i have a question for you brendan and
then and i remember i grabbed dana
because i was so excited i'm picking him
up he goes bro your nose i know what's
wrong with you just feel your nose and i
go to feel i'm like where the [ __ ] and
it's like touching your ear yeah so
you're right
your nose
you kind of
like a lot of these stories are
surprising right like because you you
kind of led with you know slow athletic
white guy cappuccino
you're a human
this is faux what's your
meaning are you like you're knocking
these dudes out you're winning the
golden glove thing and your dad's
surprised like were you just faster
stronger mentally tougher what was your
but again
i think i think because of the my
perspective
our definition of athletic is completely
different yes there's levels to the game
there's levels for sure it's like you
know i had a rich friend growing up
compared to the
rich friend i have
that guy's [ __ ] dirt but like there's
levels to everything so no question so i
think like i'm not kane velasquez so to
me like
now that i'm older and have success in
comedy and podcasting i can look back at
it and go damn at least getting a sean
there feels pretty good man getting the
ufc being ranked in the top 10 in the
world pretty good dude but at the time
is a failure i felt like a
loser man let me ask you it took years
to get over that but stay different
usually i wouldn't
this is recent for me like probably in
the last year i've started talking more
about fighting usually i don't talk
about why why is that i don't know
emotional or is it like yeah i don't
know i don't know but because i want to
be taken so serious as a comic yeah
like my manager like no fighting
questions
but let me ask you did you get into
fighting i know you say you just get
stay in the shade because my dude i was
i was joking with that my story is
eerily similar to yours you're just way
better at it at every step of the level
i was like i'm [ __ ] great value
brendan schaub this sucks dude but
you're a knockoff brown i'm walmart
you're schmend and schmelz over here but
the
so i got into mma after baseball didn't
work out because i had nothing i had all
that the whole time i was playing ball
all i wanted to do was make money i was
like dude i've i fell out of love with
the game and i'm like if i just made
money i'd be the happiest guy in the
world my girl left me not making any
money traveling the course of the world
my father's saying the same thing i get
a contract to go play in korea and i'm
like this is my big break dad i'm going
to korea going to play ball for 60 grand
like tom selleck and mr b yeah i know
that's sad and my dad broke you down the
mustang dad broke it down he was like i
just want you to understand you're 25
your big break is to make 60 grand in
the third world country and you're
you're still doing this
god damn it yeah all right so i'm out
and now you know two years later i'm
doing pharmaceutical sales like every
other drop out making more money i ever
thought i'd make in my life
suicidal i hated everything about my
life got into jiu jitsu all this other
stuff was good at it started fighting
but at the whole time i was doing that
all i was doing was chasing the failure
yeah all i was doing was was chasing
that failure to stick with you and i'm
wondering like with you with football
and everything like that you put
everything in your life you walk on you
could have quit at any point you kept
rising to the challenge rising and
challenge at that point were you like i
i still haven't reached the mountaintop
i got to find a new mountain i got i got
to prove to myself yeah i don't know
it's a mountaintop but i i think a lot
of things like in office you've uh
accomplished this it's like a lot of
people
if they get labeled as a fighter a
football player like that sticks with
them that that stuff i never care about
like the labels like even back then no i
never viewed myself as just a football
player just a fighter just a comic ever
and then i've also never ever ever in my
life done anything for money nothing
stand up podcasting nothing's ever for
money
if it's good and the content's out there
hopefully the money comes if not i'm i i
love to go with it good with it got it
like my shows in florida they could but
i should be paying them i don't care
i mean i'm glad that don't tell the
bookers that because you're having that
much fun don't tell them you have much
fun
i want to go back i want to go back so
question i got two boys i'm asking it
for a different reason i'm not nine and
eight so i want to go back to
how long did you train to box what's the
total timeline from the day you started
training to you winning those three
fights two days in a row six and now
three months okay so here's my question
for you were you were you a street
fighter were you my brother was so so so
he was this is your brother yeah that's
my older brother he's my manager too so
you your tour manager so you were the
fighter you fought yeah he has anger
issues
so he's your older brother you pick on
you as a kid oh dude i was my record
against him like one in seventy thousand
dollars
but every other time he was taking that
ass down
but bad bad bad bad yeah we have to go
to anger management and [ __ ] yeah he has
issues but but what i'm asking is like
he's better now he's better now it seems
like very likable did the kids in aurora
would did they fear him like
that's what i'm asking they feared him
but not me now you you were the fun guy
let's hang out let's party with him but
man i don't want to mess with you
correct like if you mess with me i'll
mess with my butt but this is kind of
where i want to go this one i want to go
i'm looking at the model right on how
this thing works so
i know guys that trained boxing for six
years and they're still not golden
gloves yes okay
you go you're an athlete you come and
you start boxing three months later boom
you're winning six and under you win a
big fight hey golden gloves champion now
you're making the next round on you you
pop sees you knocking out the guy that
there's no way that's going to be taking
place
how much of this is
pure athleticism how much of it is
purely genetics how much of it is a guy
can come off the street as a football
player you know who's a full-on athlete
get in the ring and fight because we're
seeing what's going on today a lot of
these guys that are not working it's not
working out so that's what i'm trying to
say so where was it where you
had the edge over your opponents even
though you've only trained boxing for
three months and you're not like a
street fighter no yeah i think the
mentality i just to me i like uh i just
always outworked everybody always even
in three months but three months is not
a long time it's not a long time but i
was around like greatness i had a great
coach and then i think you know athletic
ability is a big thing yeah and then
toughness is a really really big thing
especially at the golden gloves level
like toughness is
huge
that's why you're asking those questions
about how tough the mafia guys are
you're obsessed with toughness i'm not
i'm not saying i don't really like this
no i hear you no i'm not i'm just
curious like yeah do we think they're
tough like like that was that the the
the iceman killer like the man you
killed all those guys
yeah like
you're talking about a serial killer
like these guys are [ __ ] serial
killers and we idolize them like these
guys aren't [ __ ] man yeah you can put
that gun down and take off your [ __ ]
armani suit i got some friends that beat
the [ __ ] out of him that's like the the
yeah from friday the the pops remember
he's like you think you're tough with a
gun sure this is what makes you tough
this is what makes you a man but this is
he said it perfectly before man the
levels so like there's guys that have
been wrestling their whole life and
they're really really really good sick
technical wrestlers and they're as tough
as nails and they lead face first and
everything
but they're not strong and they're not
big and they're not fast so somebody
who's big strong fast learns a little
bit of technique there's nothing that
guy can do to them then ask her you know
so they always talk about like you know
technique will be you know size and
athleticism yeah until sizing
athleticism learns a little bit of tech
correct but then you get to a certain
level the level you got to where then
you got the athlete who has the
technique but but even that caught up
with me like i felt like i was a cheat
code in a video game because i excelled
so fast through the rankings like
knocked out crow cop who has a million
years experience former world champion i
knock him out i'm ranked in the top ten
and they're like here's noguera in
brazil which i asked for here's big nog
in brazil i'm like i'm gonna smoke this
old man
you're thinking that i was like yeah i
was like i'm going to destroy this dude
in his hometown brazil and then you know
i ended up getting knocked down that
fight
but because i was
it was a cheat code man because i was
athletic really athletic really really
big but eventually you're going to come
across where experiences came
considering because because no guerra
has seen the big athletic young kid with
a good right hand who's very athletic
and fast so when i i remember throwing
all these faints at him he's not
reacting like what the [ __ ] is going on
he's seen it a million times like he
wasn't impressed so eventually if you
don't have that experience and the ufc
is not a not a league where you want to
try and gain expansion and get cut so
what do you think is going to happen
with this model that's taking place
right now
where jake paul is going through all
these fights you know whether it's uh
robinson and then you know ascrine and
you got woodley do you think this ends
anytime soon it ends when
see
he's a little different because
i'm impressed they're friends i'll be
honest before i'm biased but i'm
impressed with him because who's your
favorite boxer you like mike tyson who
you like roy jones canelo right all good
fighters maybe hagler or some [ __ ]
whoever you like
look at their first four fights they
fought your ups yes they smoke they're
fighting [ __ ] cans yeah jake paul
even though he's you know the nate
robinson's a throwaway but ben askren uh
woodley twice
for his first four fights is insane
for him to put him away like that and i
know people want to hate himself but
there's a lane for that and it's very
impressive what he's done and the amount
of money amount of attention that he's
doing because remember logan paul and
jake paul they could air [ __ ] on youtube
live and make millions of dollars but
they chose the hardest route in the game
and you got to respect that brandon i
saw robbie lawler beat ben askren to
death and him not get knocked out you're
telling me that
you're one of the guys that thinks it's
staged isn't it you've been in sports
that's what i'm saying no i i know ben
very well and i have him on my show
right before and he goes i go he goes
i'm in la man let me because i do a show
called food truck diaries and he goes
let me come on the show i'm like yeah no
doubt i mean we're doing la because i'm
training with freddie roach dude that's
perfect he gets ready for jake this is
great and i find out he was he didn't
train he didn't he just wanted the money
he looked out of shape he didn't train
yeah so what he did is he went to
freddie got the pictures for the gram so
everyone thinks he's training he didn't
put in the time he was like i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna get the payday how does
he make money right now though he's very
he's really really big in crypto and
then he has a huge wrestling huge
wrestling academy
okay you got it that's the model got it
ben one of the smartest people here very
sharp sharp dude
you can't be that witty and talk and not
be smart woody guys are you he would he
was always very quick then i give it to
you that's a very cerebral sarcastic
poking pissing you off you know he had a
very for him he barely trained didn't
take it serious he was like and he was
like i don't think he can fight if he
and he said this on my show he goes if
he can box him a little bit i'm [ __ ]
i'll get knocked down the first round he
goes but i don't think he can but if you
can i'm [ __ ] he said that so you did
once
it's 100 for the record for the thousand
people listening it's 100 legit these
fights
dude
i know whitley's a really good friend
too i'm telling woodley's such a he has
so much pride if you went hey dude i
think he made five million which you
know it's not life-changing he gave him
five million hey
you're we're gonna knock you flat on
your face you're gonna be a [ __ ] meme
for the rest of your life but we're
gonna give you five million see that's
that's he's not doing that and and
remember woodley's
bona fide first ballot hall of famer
dude he's not doing that i'm telling you
dude that shot was [ __ ] cool yeah you
know the clip that everyone's showing
where he's going like this you know you
saw that sign that's like social and
then right afterwards
well he's not signing up for that
there's guys from the other side that
say it's common sense you don't drop
that why are you dropping a left like
you've been taught he's exhausted yeah
and he even said it he says i made them
i can't believe i dropped it and the
fights don't get me wrong the fights
suck short times you hate that i said
that the the fight sucked but also like
you have some experience in fighting
right my worst fight when i fought andre
alaska in vancouver we are training
partners we know each other so well so
those guys fought before so you're
everything's hesitant because you know
what he's really good at he knows what
you're good at so it makes for a shitty
fight
i hated that yeah i hated that rematch
so you think jake can control his
destiny
um to a certain extent i think you could
do like a tommy fury again and destroy
him oh you think he'll take down tommy
fury that's that's his easiest fight
that he's going to have what i thought
he's not the beast no no no you ever
seen his record
his first fight you find a guy who's
ready 1 in 126.
i'm not making this up look it up bring
up wikipedia that's joe glass from uh
that's joe glass it's his first six
fights it's like one in 26 oh and 28
one and nine like you see
you don't think he's good at all no he's
gonna get destroyed you think he's just
like a pretty boy
yeah jake's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
him okay so who does he lose to it's
gonna get dicey when he fights like a
nate diaz and the mazva dolls and the
conor mcgregors like the guys who
actually like
stand ups their forte it's gonna get way
bigger than them did you guys are five
eight one sixties you saw legit six two
you saw what canelo said canelo was like
why don't you come let's spar he says
you come let's part you know because
he's calling him out you know where he's
going my thing with that too it's like
dude he has four fights canelo i mean
you know he's getting all this attention
which all these boxers hate because they
you know they can't sell [ __ ] you
know training gotta respect jake for
what he's doing man gotta respect the
stars
but he's gonna run you know but it's
still brilliant because he's like oh i
want to get to 10-0 and then he's you
know he's going to retire and move on to
mma but
for him who's going to move on to mma
jake well they were legit wrestlers
brendan jake's going to move on to him
yeah he said he's going to do one fight
in mma but he wants to be 10-0 in uh
boxing now he's talking about playing in
the nfl yeah well but 10-0 is gonna be
tough for me because because he can only
go so far before he runs into some real
guys but here's the thing if his things
to make money think about this
so he fights conor even if he loses
you're still getting one to two more
huge fights he's walking away probably a
hundred million after those fights
it's brilliant brilliant i gotta start
fighting so so uh question is this what
is this hurting who is it helping
meaning this whole you know celebrity
fighting where anybody can come out uh
who's losing is this good for dana is it
bad is it pissing dang off is it good
for boxing is it bad for boxing i think
it's good for everybody tell me what i
think it's good for everybody because i
think you're seeing guy a guy in jake
paul who's bringing attention to fighter
pay and uh showing that he controls his
own destiny he literally it's his
production he's you know getting the
benefits from all of it so i think if
ufc fighters are smart they can take
something and learn something from that
so it doesn't hurt dana yes ufc can't be
hurt dana's brilliant so he can't be
hurt but you know dana anytime this
competition he's going to [ __ ] on it but
i think it's good for everybody boxing
ufc just brings attention to the combat
special do it all the other sports too
like if i were kyrie irving right now
i'd be like screw it i don't want to go
back to the nba a million dollars a game
i'll put up a million you put all you
want thousands i'll play you one on one
on show time i'll play 10 guys at night
but if jake gets knocked out by a diaz
does that does this stardom fade meaning
like all right
everyone wants to see this kid get
knocked out you agree everybody wants to
see that sure right except for his
whatever 40 million subscribers
i think half of them want to see him get
i don't think so right i think we live
in it we're older and we live on the
social media which isn't real man it's
not real regardless people would like to
see him get knocked out but when he does
do you think that people will still pay
to see 100 yeah you think they'll still
keep going i think even when he loses
that there's going to be a rematch
clause in that fight he's going to make
money so america loves you he's set up
well look at logan paul's record he's
what one two yeah oh two and one oh two
and one and anybody here ksi people
still want to watch this guy fight well
i think his upside is way bigger than
jake he's got like one let me ask you oh
you think disagree disagree you think
jake paul has bigger upside than logan
paul yeah because jake paul wants an
actual career in boxing logan paul wants
to fight the most famous guys to make
the most money possible
he's talking beyond fighting right now
i'm not even saying the president likes
somebody oh you're saying this i'm
saying bigger than fighting oh yeah
logan yeah have you have you guys had
him i'm surprised you haven't
interviewed him we haven't yet brilliant
guy yeah he seems like it's smart
see the way he moves smart these it's
not accident like a lot of these guys
it's not an accident
even the vines back in the data were
hilarious to begin with logan paul's
hilarious business-wise monster and you
gotta appreciate the hustle you are you
think of yourself as an adrenaline
junkie man no not at all not at all so i
mean you've lived your whole adult life
here seeking bigger and bigger and
bigger spotlights i'm an adrenaline
junkie 100 i don't know so and when it's
quiet and there's nobody around you're
you're happy you're not itching like man
i got to find something to do i got to
do some crazy [ __ ] here no i mean i i
get restless because i want to because i
feel like you can always be working
which is a problem especially i have
kids i have a five and two year old so
that can be a problem where you're
always thinking about work but drilling
junk you know like i never jump out of
plane and [ __ ] i don't drive fast i have
cool cars i don't drive fast i can't i
can't do two days really no
pat
have you ever driven fast no i've had my
license suspended a few times yeah
what's the fastest you've ever driven
i just i'm this isn't a flex i just got
a new ferrari and i was going down the
the five in uh california driving back
from san diego yeah i have like 115.
115. 115. that's like a wednesday i
don't i don't drive i'm like he's an
adrenaline junkie i don't want it
america that he doesn't drive an
adrenaline junkie that won't go in the
car with him i don't know you you drive
like i go with this guy we're in uh
we're in a bentley
we weren't a bentley in l.a bentley
it was the four-door was it the con was
it the moose you're asking me i gotta
take an uber everywhere that was really
cool though yeah it was uh
660 horsepower we're on what's the 405
405 yes okay
405 l.a
during covet so it's like not that
legend just for the record it's
all
he goes let's let's open this baby up
let's see what we got
dude
he it felt like we were going
60. yeah he goes you know how fast we
were just going right there 150.
he goes let's remix this thing allegedly
he hits it again
now i'm like paying attention
165. on the 405. dude yeah there's a
place to do it though we were going to
when it's six wide open coveted cops
aren't even that's right
[Laughter]
the flight takes off in an hour and 15
from the old office oh my gosh i forgot
the old office to the airport to dfw was
about 45. like they started boarding by
the time that we got in the car we made
the flight wow good for you i've never
seen anything like that
go be a cop when i got out of the
military i'm like this is a good right
you know military you get out you were
in a marine so when you get out you're
thinking you get additional points to be
a firefighter or a cop right i go to be
a cop i take the test
and uh they said you can't be a cop i
said why can't i be a cop i was 21 years
old with 16 speeding tickets that's not
going to happen i said you realize i'm
going to catch the bad guy better than
anybody else
you broke the law too many times [ __ ]
ricky bobby over here
so you got you got comedy big
personality huge body athlete college
athlete wwe it's like first ballot hall
of fame wwe what happened here man no
way man no
uh with the podcasting i have my thick
boy network so we do a you know i bought
my own studio i run everything out i
hired my own staff i get the thick boy
merch i'm talking like 10 years ago 15
years ago
no no no no i don't know what a vintage
man what a miss
yeah with the personality in the next
razor ramona
[Music]
so aspiration it wasn't like i'm gonna
go
i'm uh you know pro athlete you see the
rock i'm you know
playing miami dolphins and i'm going to
go this right now okay i'm going to go
do movies i'm going to act i'm going to
pursue this like for you to say i'm
going to go fighting then i'm going to
go comedy and then eventually i want to
be able to do xyz that was not the case
for you no i just go and then if i enjoy
it then i just build the best team
around me and then try to have the most
fun and hopefully it works out got it so
what's next for you what do you want to
do next
big project that excites you it'd be
literally the the thick boy network in
my own studio and we do several shows
out of there you know similar what you
guys have here we you know we do a
million shows out of there
um
it's funny you asked me that because uh
rob dared he was on the show and he he
was looking at things and he's like so
what's the plan he kept going what's the
plan i'm like dude quit [ __ ] asking
what the plan is
and then i made fun of him for it and
kind of shut him down which is probably
not the smart thing to do because he's a
brilliant dude and then a week goes by
and goes hey i need to talk to you it's
been bothering me all week man you got
to have a plan and use can you uh
facetime tomorrow at four i'm like sure
dude so he facetimed me and he was just
you know he's a good mentor to have he's
like you're 38 when i was 38 you're the
exact same as me man you're making this
much money you're doing this you think
everything's all good but i never had a
plan and he said uh another guy asked
him like what's your plan and really
helped him out so
i'm coming up with a plan what i want
yeah super jack it's a great company man
like
when you see this how much of it is um
the individual cast and division of who
they want to be how much of it is the
agent or the manager from ca saying hey
have you thought about this i think you
can be xyz i think you can be you know
that that that i wonder if that
conversation is questionable are you
pitching are you getting pitched like
what's the they've pitched me on a
number of uh auditions for certain
things
but it's just we're in a different world
now so it's like
let's say i get booked to do some movie
unless i'm [ __ ] the next batman or
something it doesn't make sense for me
to vancouver for eight weeks miss my
kids
miss all the podcasts all the stand up
i'll make more money doing my owning my
own business doing all the other stuff
that i wouldn't be on this close to
saying make more money doing only fans
man oh man well you never know i'm gonna
say never you never know somehow
you gotta have a plan you never know
man well by the way by the way this is
exactly what they don't want to hear no
they don't want to hear that what he
just said because the level of the level
of uh desperation
people give me any job man i'll take
anything give me anything you got me
i mean my
agent at ca and the guys they won't mind
me saying this but we butt heads because
they only touch touring or if they you
know if there's an acting gig or they
you know they sold my special for me and
so
you eat what you kill for me i'm not
your traditional johnny depp where you
get 10 of everything i do the podcast
network and my shows completely you
don't have an overall deal then no not
at all you negotiate that yeah all that
yeah so they don't touch anything in my
podcasting they don't touch it man i run
that all myself
again different model that's the like
completely
sat there told the story about how he
sold uh uh a bronx tale and it was the
most incredible story i've ever heard in
my life there's only two guys in the
history of hollywood did this him and
sylvester stallone long story short dude
is broke people that have watched the
podcast you know which podcast this was
broke
has a car that that's the bottom of it's
rusted out in the passenger seat doesn't
have a bottom he gets offered a hundred
grand for bronx tail but he can't play
the lead he can't play sonny turns it
down 200 grand turns it down 500 turns
it down cold million and if you if you
say no we're dropping you as a client
turns it down no damn says i'm going to
be sunny ends up signing the deal with
robert de niro he's sunny his whole
career goes you know analyze this
everything else for but the ability to
say no
nobody's saying no no yeah but for every
one story like that during that time
there are tens uh yeah of thousands like
you know spring saying hey your voice
sucks you know but you got good lyrics
you could be a good writer but you're
not a
for every one of you
you know the rocky story he sold his dog
you know everybody's heard those stories
but the business model has changed for
good and bad because there's no
there's like no criteria to start your
own podcast there's no criteria for you
you know to get famous off youtube and
then try and do stand up because you can
sell tickets they're going to book you
no matter if you're the worst comic in
the world so it's it's a you know it's a
blessing and a curse so the industry
still tries to kind of we talked about a
little bit off here they still like look
down their nose a little bit like
youtube and they're like you know but at
the same time i think it's because
it takes the power away from them like
it's an internet i'm trying to figure it
out though it's an international casting
call i mean you're out here talking to
the whole world and then the world can
decide whether they like you're not it's
not somebody in an ivory tower in
downtown lake green lighting you the
world is green lighting yeah no yeah
hollywood doesn't have the power anymore
all right this guy can do this this guy
can't they really don't i mean you saw
what ricky gervais said at the at the
awards yeah the oscars we got up he says
listen you guys may well just throw in
the towel and give all the you know
words to netflix
[Laughter]
but he's right i mean that was ricky
gervais every time he gives this message
there's depth in his thinking that guy's
a brilliant guy yeah i love him
his speech i hope they booked this guy
again i really hope that i don't know if
they're going to do it but they're
scared too yeah i'll never my god but if
you could play any role though what
would you play if you had your druthers
what would you play uh i would do like
uh a comedy movie with all my guys like
theovon crystalia brian like all the
boys like the adam sandler model you
bring all your boys in
sandal earlier so yeah adam sandler you
got a good adam sandler impression no
not at all you can't do a little hill no
nothing i did meet him i did meet him
what yeah i was at the movies uh with my
kiddos and my girl and i see him it it's
rare for me to get there at the movie
theater
and i was like oh [ __ ] and my girl's
like well i'm like that's my north star
that's adam sandler she's like you gotta
say something like i'm not gonna say
anything because you know i'm not gonna
say anything it's gonna be weird i don't
know who i am she's like now you have
the comedy store i'm sure he sees like
you at the end problem like i've never
seen him there i'm telling you i've
never seen him yeah and i go in the
bathroom and he's in the bathroom no it
sure is [ __ ] like i can see something
hey how's it hanging oh wow [ __ ] hey man
how's the move
and then we then we then we walk out of
the bathroom and he's there and he goes
hey and he could tell i was looking at
him and i'm like telling my kids about
him he was hey and i walk over what's up
mr sandler he goes you're the you're the
tough guy that does comedy right and i
was like holy [ __ ] he knew you
you played hard to get and then he's
like yeah yeah yeah you're the guy yeah
so apparently wow he said he said
athlete adam sandler
huge apparently the way things
that's the inverse that's how you
compete with jake paul you bring on like
bill murray and will ferrell if you're
the cleveland cavaliers right now and
have them be 11 and 12 at the on the
bench yeah he plays pickup all the time
yeah you see the video's always going
very well you got any shots b-ball
skills or no uh a little bit you have
the court at the house i play a little
bit yeah okay yeah where do you live
in l.a yeah what
like right on the edge there and with
everything going on during like topanga
topanga or like yeah
no right off like topanga there wells
into panga yeah so my office was at uh
warner center marriott
seventeen five hundred i think it's
sixteen seven some seventy five hundred
eventually right across from pf chance
yes you know what pft yeah that's why i
took my son in the movies last week yeah
that's that's the movie theater i would
go all the time yep i know right across
i love it over there magiano's on the
other side they build a whole mall
everything by the way probably the best
mall in l.a is the topanga mall by far
by far even better than and then then my
studios thick boy studios is literally
up the street in calabasas right by that
irwin next door the irwin up there
you're in like a heavenly place yeah so
you have no plans of leaving no you're
going to stay there
yeah we were talking about it before i
came in here yeah you know
all my friends left which you know makes
me sad i miss them but i think for me i
love la i love i hate the politics but i
love la and it doesn't to be honest
doesn't affect me that much when we were
in like
you know 2020 2021 the height of covet
it was north korea it was it was tough
man but you know that those days are
over now it's pretty open the i can do
spots all over town now and like again
it's my own studio so we don't require
masks or anything like that so didn't
bother me i'm a homebody so we're good
and why did all your friends leave
uh you know rogan left because it made
sense for him you know to save on taxes
and austin he's going to build the
comedy scene in austin segura same
reason moved to austin you know he makes
more money than god so a lot of those
guys left for that reason theo just
wants something different so he moved to
nashville so you know the crew the crew
kind of joey diaz moved to new jersey
this is like a sad epilogue
to stand by me like the sandlot this is
the sandwich it's joey's
jersey he was never seen you know i
think joey maybe just a little bit sick
of the hustle she wanted to break one to
family life slow down he's an older guy
he has a daughter but yeah i'm also
younger than all these guys yeah so it's
like you know for rogan to leave he's
been in la 30 years sugar has been there
30 years so you know i've been there 10
man you're 83 right now yeah i'm kind of
just getting my friend in the door and
like you know rogan used to always do
you know rogan and friends at the improv
in the comedy store well now shaving
friends now he's got to chop her friends
and then
you know me my favorite show that i've
ever done in my entire life was the
fight campaigns with joe rogan eddie
bravo and brian callan
well rogan moved to austin
and i called him like dude we should get
the crew back together we'll fly out
once a month to austin and do fight
companies like i'm just too busy man
he's like i got an idea why don't you do
it i was like really he's like you do it
man build your own team and you do it so
that's what i did so
you know it's a blessing and it's also a
bummer that they left man how did you
get hooked on with rogan
um okay when i was fighting the ufc he
was obviously the announcer and then him
and brian kellen are really close
and when i first moved to la we do we go
to dinners together all the time
and then um we just you know became good
friends and then rogan used to always
harp like you gotta do stand-up man
you're funny dude you're [ __ ] funny
while you were fighting yeah when i was
fighting i'm telling you get a set
together i'm telling you you can do this
like constantly that's cool tell me do
stand up do stand up to your mind dude
was rogan the guy that told you to stop
fighting and yeah
really what was that what was that
conversation like that was i i was a fan
as a fan of both his and as a fan of
rogan's that was one of the more awkward
podcasts i ever listened to what was it
what did he say
um just he could tell i had one foot in
one foot out and he's 100 right you know
rogan's very you know blunt up front
obviously the message i think is harsh
to the public
but me and him had to have such a good
relationship to me you know the only
thing that was surprising was um
i was going to do me and brian were
going to do a show
and i was like you know kind of
announced my retirement kind of not like
i was on the fence
and uh we're driving a student town
calls me hey rogan wants to do it with
us
really he goes yeah but he's gonna do
that history
so the people think that was a jre
episode that was actually a fighter in
the kid that was a fireman kid at joe
rogan's studio it was my show but on his
platform oh i didn't know that yeah most
people don't really i was actually a
fighter wow i don't know so
i and i told brian all right dude but i
don't like i don't talk about the fight
like you know i'm kind of messed up from
depressed man i want to talk about it
there's no he's not going to do that
we're not going to talk about the food
did you tell joe this or you told brian
this no i told brian i got it so i
figured he relayed that uh wait so just
a second back so you had to you had
already decided to hang them up before
that yeah because you know i've been
doing fire in the kit at that point for
about three years yeah and i was you
know starting to receive a good amount
of income from that
and
you know it was just i i was busy with
that and then i've always been really
into fashion and like my own merch so
instead of wearing like a tap out shirt
i'd create my own shirt and walk out on
that and then sell it myself online and
then reebok said you're not allowed to
do that anymore and that really made me
retire really
interesting so so so so so you so you
didn't know joe was going to ask you and
talk to you about that i had no clue
yeah but you know as he gave me a super
solid well what did he ask you what was
the actual you just told me stop
fighting he was like you can tell you're
one foot in one foot out and you're
gonna get hurt you just called your [ __ ]
out right there yeah camera what
happened after camera like this so the
whole thing he hugged me okay you know
that's what i remember we were both
pretty carry on yeah he hugged me it's
very obvious i know that was harsh man
but i love you man the reason i did this
because i love the [ __ ] out of you and
yeah and he's like but you can do like
what i'm telling you podcast and stand
up you can do this man the fyi
ninety percent of them maybe more can't
do that nine percent be generous yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying they cannot
do that so
it's like the nba you know everybody
leaves the nba like okay what's this guy
going to be doing dude you don't have
the personality to be an analyst you
don't have a personality to be
commentated you've got to have the
personality the humor all of that so
brendan he was right yeah
i mean come on okay
in hindsight yeah he's right and then
even people think i've issues with dan i
have no issues with dana if i saw him
give him a big hug but he because him
signing that reebok deal at the time
that gave me the fuel to get to where i
wanted to get so i was so mad at him i
was so mad when he signed that reebok
dana dana white i'm so mad and we had a
conversation on the phone it did not go
well and uh i just kept calling call him
out on shows but he put a [ __ ] box of
pringles on my shoulder some people have
a chip on their shoulder at a [ __ ]
pringle box on my shoulder i was so mad
but it gave me the fuel to get to where
i want to go
and now that i'm on the outside looking
in
you know i've made it this far i would
give him a hug and like thank god you
did that man
like i owe all my stuff to him man you
channeled that rage artistically too
which is like that i mean that's
something that
because i didn't want to be a failure
not i wasn't doing to prove to dana like
told you i could do it but i just didn't
want to be that guy that left the ufc
and then you know was [ __ ] holding
mitts at the ufc sure well i meant that
they would scoff in that yeah what are
you going to do oh dude i'm going to do
stand up yeah say that again you're a
big fan of dana white though i'm a big
fan very highly i actually want to ask
him a question
i want to be very clear i'm i'm a very
big fan of danny oh it's very obvious
you made no issues yeah but here's
here's what i want to ask you so uh uh
in the
in ufc today okay versus 10 years ago
who's more important today
a face of the ufc that's marketable for
example usman's not marketable he's a
ridiculous fighter
but is he a guy that's going to come out
and you know do one of these why do you
think goosebumps he's not a connor
that's not your point he's just giving
an example no no i will make it very
clear i think technically the guy's a
monster
but conor yeah some people put him in
the top five conor makes you money okay
colors are once in a lifetime kobe means
kobe makes you money kobe talks [ __ ]
jorge masridal makes you money right so
chelsea talks [ __ ] but i don't know was
he a money yeah he was a money fighter
yeah was chelsea eyeballs well i've
never even heard of his name but wait a
minute but wait a minute he was gonna
let you get close he was a money fighter
for ufc but back then they didn't pay
the way they it was a different uh model
but he brought eyeballs to yeah you go
of course you brought eyeballs to the
spot yeah so you have a point but but
what i'm trying to go to right now is
the following what what matters more
is a ridiculous one of the greatest
promoters of all time dana white more
important today to the sport of ufc or
is a great face important to the face of
us dana white okay you know i i agree
with you i agree with you on that look
at the business model too because now
they've gone away from pay-per-views
which pay-per-view is generated just off
stars and now they make their nut off
the espn deal getting whatever 600
million a year put on 42 fights on espn
so espn doesn't care if it's conor or
some guy you've never heard of that's
right ufc is making their money no one's
more famous or bigger in the sport than
dana white the two most famous people
aren't fighting it's joe rogan dana
white sure cage side making very true
what a great point what a great piece of
work
so conor mcgregor makes a ton of sense
joining them on the outside so this is
my question for you this is my question
from kirsten know what he says who do
you think okay dana's not going to be
able to do this for 30 more years okay
he's going to go for a while but to do
it 30 more years i don't know about that
is there anybody you would say
if anybody could do dana's job today
it'd be dot dot dot is there anybody
that could do his job today not to the
level that he does it at um because i do
think you ought to be kind of a shark
because a lot of fighters are pretty
caring despite what people think so um
but it'd be a fighter it'd be like a guy
like brian stan if you know who he is
military background and he went on he's
working for some huge venture capital
company now he's like the head of it
making all this money a guy like tim
kennedy who's uh who's a special forces
guy
who's brilliant but also caring would
probably take care of the fighters a
little better um daniel cormier dominic
cruz somebody who what an angle you took
yeah so so you're saying fighters as
tough as they are deep down inside their
kids they're they're sensitive they want
to be able to have somebody that cares
about them that takes care of thank you
i think you need some of that in today's
world because dana's a businessman and
which i get you know people won't
complain about fighter pay or you know
could you know complain about things but
then we all have apple phones
complain about the way you know apple
treats their employees yeah i wonder
like when you're saying that i look at
it from a maybe a different angle
because of being a business myself
business yeah no i'm not thinking
straight let me give you my insight i
want you to push back and see uh what
angle you see this so i look at uh roger
goodell okay
who likes roger goodell who hates roger
goodell okay roger goodell just signed a
godfather killing ridiculous contract
making 25 million a year private jet for
the rest of his life and you know health
all this stuff that he negotiated and he
got it right
so what do you know this this and we've
had the conversation about the guy and
the next thing you know
all the owners made boom they love him
but here's the point though here's a
point of amazon streaming if you think
about the fact that the owners made that
money who else makes that money right
mahomes gets a half a million dollars it
trickles down right so all i'm thinking
is i think sometimes
at the top
you need an sob like a dana white that's
going to be able to sit down with these
other media bullies that's going to push
them like i don't give a [ __ ] who you
are you ain't going to be able to bully
this guy versus the other guys are more
compassionate the proper corporate guys
that are going to be diplomatic it's
like hey you know yeah let's do side
deal wink wink i don't think dana does
any winkling deal he's not doing
anything yeah that's a good point yeah
you need a savage in there and
unfortunately you know to make an
omelette crack some eggs and that's what
the ufc does this is the only thing i
disagree with that's a good point it's
the only thing i'll disagree with that
right there there can only be so much
circus there has to be some go to go
with the show like
meaning like it's not gonna turn into
bare knuckle fighting and it's just
whoever the two best [ __ ] talkers and
these guys are gonna fight we're gonna
make this bmf belt like they're getting
past that there's still people that want
to see gsp fight there's still people
that want to see kamarulism fight
there's still people that want to see
the best in the world
but i'm not just talking about ufc or
boxing like look jake paul he's
disrupting that's great but when every
influencer in the world starts throwing
wild hands and hugging each other i mean
there's the sweet science is something
that's beautiful to watch because none
of us can do it for sure you know what
i'm saying so you saw when the tick tock
youtube challenge that thing was a
disaster
man right you saw you know what i'm
talking about you'll pay you'll pay 200
to watch somebody in the nba play
because they do things that you can't do
you won't pay five dollars no you want
to see that
basketball that's what i'm saying so
that's why nobody goes to wnba on a
certain on a certain level they're
pushing and they're pushing and they're
pushing but i think they're going to
kill the golden goose the further they
get away and who's the golden goose well
dude right right now i think the nba is
doing the worst job possible by far
boar's job possible they they hate their
fans look at the ratings
they actively hate their fans and
they're filled with superstars that's
the thing so i mean they're alienating
their fan yeah their fan base by doing
some of the political stuff they did and
it's also when they did it they're not
doing it now you're saying you're
circling i don't agree with them
yeah they really [ __ ] them and then
the analytics too man i mean the
analytics look i get it like i the whole
reason i had an opportunity with the
cardones was because of moneyball like
you know i struck out a lot and then i
hit the ball to the moon and that's all
i did that's great right
but that's a really boring style of
baseball when you have nine guys i i
challenge anybody watching this watch
the 2001 world series between arizona
diamondbacks and new york yankees
baseball can't get better than that it's
a fun game there's something happening
on every why though because there's
action there's activity
i mean there's so much light there's
also steroids yeah steroids exactly i
think there should be steroids
you think it should be illegal steroids
in baseball it's not hurting anybody
they're in a [ __ ] ball yeah i want to
see the guys juice to the [ __ ] max
cranking home runs listen having a
little person did anybody get mad at
brad pitt for being juiced to the hilt
and troy having 19 abs yeah they're not
hurting anybody it's basically
legalized steroids let me tell you let
me say
yo what are your thoughts on that you
have an opposing audience
so you're just encouraging give us your
argument that's the argument
arnold schwarzenegger
all the box office we had an entire
conversation
last podcast about drugs okay about
pills and about cocaine and i'm like
look marijuana ain't that bad
now we're like shoot up
throw some random [ __ ] there's a
difference there's a difference big
difference i give you the big difference
i'll give you the big difference okay so
in 200 uh
2001 2001 morgan stanley 911 2001 i go
to uh mr olympia okay
i'm in shape
i'm ready i'm thinking about going into
the world to compete right it's either
gonna be i'm gonna go be a stock broker
with morgan stanley dean witter i'm
gonna go be a bodybuilder i go to mr
olympia oh but this is real you actually
competed yeah you know i'm sorry no no
no never never happened
yeah i was but this is in the army i was
competing so that's cool so i go into i
go to mr olympia so i'm like i'm gonna
find out what this life looks like okay
so i walk around and i start hanging out
with these guys we start partying and
some of the big names at the time they
you know if you follow bodybuilding you
know these names i've interviewed mostly
i'm gonna rip them off for you or no no
no the name's off if you want you gotta
you would get the name oh yeah you'd get
the name yeah cormier was a party guy
aaron baker all these guys right so
anyway so i go and i say so
tell me what it takes to be mr olympia
okay the guy says you want me mr olympia
he says yeah i said i won't know what it
takes
i don't want to be a mr olympia
competitor
i want to be myself mr olympia right now
i want to be arnold tell me yeah by the
way phil heath used to sit in this seat
right here keith is my boy yeah yeah
denver guy
that's right that's where
he used to work out the same gym and he
also went to university of colorado
that's right that's right that's right
he's been on fire the kid great guy yeah
he's a phenomenal guy absolutely so let
me go back to this so
i'm i'm looking at this guy i'm like
listen i want to kind of be mr olympia
and if i'm going to do this i'm not
doing it to compete i want to be the mr
olympia it says okay let me explain to
what what we take
let me make the list okay
this this this this this this this this
i won't give the name who was what we
went through the whole list of things
you need to take seven pages long then
you're six four six five you're gonna be
off season 350
and no one has ever won mr olympia at
six four six five the tallest guy that
won it was six two and a half 235 245
his name is arnold during the days where
bodybuilding was very different nowadays
now they're all five nines ronnie
coleman won it he was like five uh nine
five ten three ten three hundred nine
yeah ironically maybe five ten three
five hundred percent
phil is phil's five nine right yeah but
ronnie looks bigger no no no to your
point i would tell people this all the
time and i when i was called but but let
me make myself finish my point the point
is the following here if you're gonna go
at that level like you look at lebron do
you think lebron just takes [ __ ] i
don't know about that you look
just you know maybe maybe
just wink wink it's all good
season what percentage of nba players
you think are smoking wheat
probably all of them 80 plus percent
yeah okay so but they're not like it i
agree it's less harmful than steroids
no but there's a there's a return
there's a return
there's a big difference between weed
cocaine lsd special k you know
there's a very different all the good
stuff between that and
steroids there's a very big difference
there okay go go meaning very bounce
okay juan gonzalez used to be like this
right he came in he was hitting 40 home
runs then he started juicing
then he wasn't hitting the way he was
hitting before it actually didn't help
him as much right some of the guys
because you it's good to be like this
sometimes it widens up a little bit it
doesn't work for everybody right yeah
pictures you're doing it more for your
shoulders your elbows recovery that's
more so it's not like you're doing it
like roger clements wasn't benching six
plates and you know wanting to go
compete roger clemens was recovering
faster having 21 game seasons
and why do you think lebron's playing so
long at such a high level yeah are you
thinking are you weird but bring that
back to baseball you're saying hey go at
it do steroids bro it's a libertarian
concept the only thing is like for me if
weed is legal
you got to look at that steroid same
similar kind of a conversation i see
steroids in a similar kind of
conversation
i see it as a similar type of a
you choose to
you choose to put it in your body what
is performance in hand let me give you a
different perspective right like that
term performance enhancing like [ __ ]
used to drive me out of my mind i never
took steroids but i did everything
possible within the rules to mimic the
effect of stem steroids we all didn't
everything everything so i'm taking so
instead of taking one clean shot from a
doctor i'm taking 15 freaking seven cato
dheas and then another like t-bomb and
then you're a freaking physicist over
there but this is what's happening right
like year one that's legal year two that
stuff's illegal i never broke any rules
was i performing enhancing drugs like
it's this it's such a mockery and now my
body's like a bunch of melted crayons
because i completely turned my
metabolism
baseball nobody's getting hurt either
you're hitting the ball so you guys are
all on the same page steroids basically
when it's professional this is the truth
the biggest mistake i ever made in the
minor leagues was not taking steroids
the biggest mistake i ever made because
once you're there your job is to make as
much money for your family as you
possibly might my my logic behind this
is
if
if it's something you're going to do to
advance
like there is a way that you're
advancing you can consider it if there
is for some people it doesn't work out
well for some people it does what are
the side effects by the way by the way
you actually do what that but that's a
great question but that's a great
question because it's illegal kids are
taking things that they shouldn't take
in quantities they shouldn't take it if
it was legal and your team doctor was
able to administer it the side effects
are negligible so you're saying if the
doctor does the larger point as far as
side effects in in those grown men
probably not much but they're not
growing a third testicle having heart
issues like you're actually saying
steroids aren't that bad for you no not
at all all right like can we get some
freaking steroids in there i got to step
out okay
the problem the problem you can run into
is if you know we have kids so if you
have a 12 year old kid who idolizes you
know uh his favorite baseball player
ryan braun or some [ __ ] like that he's
on steroids well that's going to
encourage that kid to do so at a young
age yeah so if they do it in high school
and like middle school that's where well
just like in the basketball players do
you remember any kids in high school
that were on steroids high school i
remember yeah it's a little awkward yeah
by the way it was very awkward yeah so
awkward yeah very well you have a
mustache yeah
and you're a female yeah
now the greatest swimmer in the world
though that's it you know
no no no i don't i'm telling a whole
different story with the college yeah
yeah
but again you talk about the uh lance
armstrong got caught and they they
paraded him around like a pariah and
then so should he be able to do this
this is the thing he came riding a bike
but okay so you're good to go yes you're
on a [ __ ] time okay how about you
look it up who should not be able to do
steroids i know
nfl and ufc i know why nfl
because you're physically hurting each
other so if that steroids allows him to
go zero to you know 40 yard dash faster
he's physically inflicting more pain
unless everybody's on the same
up for me man of course
i believe the last tour de france where
lance armstrong got caught
you have to go down to 15th place to
find a guy who did it
i think it was 24th maybe
24 that they would use it that did not
test positive the the two through like
20 all have been caught doing steroids
so lance was a scapegoat is what you're
saying the whole team was friends
thinking he was an [ __ ] so that's why
they went after so really yeah by the
way this goes to another name barry
bonds okay similar to barry another
[ __ ] another [ __ ] right i mean
that's nobody wants to see those guys
win
no matter what what about sammy sosa
should be in the hall of fame and the
steroids turned him white yeah uh did
you see that oh that wasn't that was
that was the bleach okay my bad might be
a lotion maybe a little yeah not enough
time in the sun maybe yeah yeah i was
weird what's going on there little he's
uh salmon salsa now
yeah
66 home runs that one season 90. i don't
know if you've seen the documentary
i was in the military i mean we had a
great time
sosa home runners i don't even like
baseball
became a fan
the fact that bud selig is in the hall
of fame after he destroyed the game in
95 and then turned a blind eye to
everything yeah those guys everything
yeah but you have kids right trying to
get him to watch baseball my son's like
get the [ __ ] out of here your son's wife
yeah he's like what the [ __ ] is this
your son's five it goes dogs like that
he's yeah he's raised by himself
but he's tough hey dad what is this
[ __ ] on tv fortnight just nothing
but video games the whole time what man
yeah he just uh you try and get a kid to
watch baseball or even boxing for that
matter
really oh yeah dylan will watch boxing i
can't get him to watch baseball can you
watch baseball boxing the watch a little
bit but unless it's like anthony joshua
or deontay wilder they're not into it
got it yeah ufc the watch yeah did you
ever do you ever show them your fights
oh yeah yeah what do they think yeah i
mean he loves it he says he wants to be
he does jiu jitsu now nice he did i
actually picked up my black belt because
of him because i've been a black belt
for years but i've never had the actual
black belt am i i never want to lie to
my son so i saw he was begged me to do
jiu-jitsu so i drive this jiu-jitsu
place
and it's like probably day four of him
competing there and you know he's good
at athletic and so
he we walk in there and you know his
coaches have black belt but you know
they're like
like 300 pound guy you're not in great
shape
and there's also there chris barley
comes in all right kid we're going to
learn about garage there was a guy named
roy nelson who was yeah i fought him
nightmare great guy
great fighter but he uh back to the
point though is again at black belt
there's different levels of black belts
there's like there could be a black belt
from one school there could be a another
black belt in there in the different
standards that's what you're saying so
my son goes dad you have a black belt i
go dude you've seen my what do you
talking blackberry yeah i submitted a
guy in the ufc man it was the first
anaconda joke ever in the heavyweight
division yeah i'm a black belt yes oh
can we show me your black bat at home
like
what i don't have like the physical
guy i know he's got them
yeah then he goes could you beat them up
like are you [ __ ] me dude them
oh my god so we got in the car i called
my coach i talked in like five years i'm
all east sound hey coach you still have
that black belt for me he's like we've
been waiting for you to pick it up i go
i'm booking my [ __ ] ticket now i'll
be there friday so me and my son fly
down to denver he's five he's five flew
down to denver he came into the school
and they had to roll with all the black
belts and they gave me my black yeah
yeah i took the belt off there's your
black belt at five previously
and what's this tiger tiger by the way
is he big like you is he a big kid yeah
okay so he's like 99 percentile type of
kid yeah five and two you said five and
two what's the two-year-old bruiser yeah
his name is bruiser no no he's his
name's boston yeah boston the bruiser
wow why boss well i don't know different
just different names we named the kid
brooklyn yeah exactly it's not like he
he probably goes to uh before christmas
where he says you know in our family dad
named us after the city they conceived
us
[Laughter]
ask you the same question i asked pat
man it's a tough question to think about
but
when you're when you're coming up like
you said you got tough because of your
environment right like you had to you
had an environment where you had to
develop personality you had developed
skill sets right now you're growing up
you got rich kids now your kids are
growing up rich your kids are growing up
in calabasas yeah la kids yep they're
[ __ ] so here's the thing very similar
to a roll roll but this is the thing
right it's like
you want to give your kids everything
that you never had sure but then you're
going to turn them into everything that
you never were correct so i mean what do
you do to make sure that
sports because there's no
the sports that'll humble him like he
they he doesn't have to go pro in sports
i'm not like that overbearing dad but
he's gonna have to play sports because
that teaches them respect
humility
toughness wins you're gonna do something
like
jiu jitsu you're gonna put him in some
kind of mma some kind of thing he's in
jiu-jitsu now four times a week he does
jitsu he does soccer he's into
everything yeah so the culture now my
kids go to the bar jiu jitsu right here
and you go there i gotta tell you man
this is good for kids like i didn't grow
up with that so i'm not like somebody
that went to it but i'm watching how
they talk to hey you know they're trying
to discipline them it's not like it's
okay it's not one of those environments
it's pretty like pretty strong it's a
good gym yeah you're around man
which is good i love that i think
there's a lot of benefits to it question
for you guys i'm gonna go to you okay
so uh uh you remember when we used to
buy newspapers and everybody would read
newspapers like 20 something years ago
in newspapers boom gone nobody's buying
newspapers magazines dogs are just
pissing on carpets all over america so
so go to blackberry go to newspaper go
to any of that stuff right okay they're
gone we don't even use black
next health remember people next time we
used to do all this stuff okay
10 years from now
20 years from now let's go 2041 okay
you got ufc
you got mma
is there going to be one that's going to
be forgotten about and the other one's
going to surpass the other one like
there's going to be a major separator
between the two sports or both boxing
and mma are going to be around ufc is
going to be around 20 years from now ufc
will i guarantee will be around boxing
needs to figure things out boxing's the
one who who are in trouble i think that
and that's another uh thing with jake
paul a plus is he's getting that yet
younger demographic into watching boxing
when before they're not watching triple
g and these guys they don't care to be
interested yeah because their dad's
probably running into it yeah so but
everyone's kind of in the ufc so i think
ufc will be around but boxing you know
they need that next big start because
you know canelo's getting older he's
probably the biggest star you got fury
you got wilder you got joshua but
they're going to need someone like uh
you know connor but in boxing to get
that younger audience
it's not jake it's not jake it's not
logan you need someone in traditional
boxing to come up through the rankings
who has the it factor like a conor
mcgregor do you think a sport is going
to be disrupted like you think there's
going to be a sport that's not primed
for that
boxing's a land of dinosaurs
from the ownership from the promoters to
the way they do things yeah think about
it also you know 12 3-minute round like
it's it's it's a lot man it's cool
they take six rounds to feel each other
out like it's tough man that's a good
point because you're not seeing anything
you're not seeing any action for me and
they don't fight really to hurt each
other anymore you're not seeing hagglers
out there yeah they're like look let's
we're going to have a trilogy here we're
going to milk they're also killing i
don't mean interrupt you they're also
killing themselves because you have you
know four major promoters so the fights
we want to see we don't see happen for
years down the road to we're over it
yeah so
they have an interesting thing but did
you hear what mayweather recently said
about the uh uh the conversation came
about when they asked him who do you
think the best heavyweight of all time
he said larry holmes over
ali they said why larry holmes he says
first of all you know ali lost to norton
three times he just kind of started
going through the whole history you know
ali didn't do this ali lost ali used to
rope a dope and you can't do that and
it's a different kind of style he used
to make people toward reminders yeah he
says to me it's larry holmes it's not
muhammad ali and then he says i think
i'm the greatest boxer of all time and
he went through the whole argument he
made about the fact that he's the
greatest boxer of all time do you have a
good argument who do you put as the
greatest boxer of all time uh floyd's
definitely up there floyd's up there i
heavyweight's tough you know when they
say you know larry holmes or muhammad
ali or mike tyson you know because of
enter holyfield you'd have to rank over
mike tyson but because we came up with
mike tyson this big scary guy and i love
people think of him i love mike tyson
but he to me he's i'm in the
conversation for greatest all time he
was the scariest of all time when he had
his run his first yeah but he looked at
his resume he wasn't beating anybody of
note the guys that he fought that he
wasn't allowed to bully lost to so you
to me he's not you know he's not you're
saying the holy spirit but i mean that's
like feels the rig bows but that's like
the atlantic's linux is better than all
of them wait a minute you push
bow ahead of tyson i don't know if i put
him ahead of tyson but we're talking
about greats yeah he he's not he's not
so he's he's he's in top three or he's
not he's to me he's the scariest okay
and at the time in the promotion and in
the past around him the pop culture like
he's by far so would you would you say
is it fair to say like if we were to
define it like you know the most
dominant player in the history the nba
shack right maybe he's not the greatest
but he's the most dominant player ever
in the history of the nba is that kind
of how you're putting it yeah okay or
tim duncan yeah
tim duncan was a monster he was a
monster but shaq came in shaq would turn
the elbow hits your face you're done you
run up and down the corner yeah he's
scared the crap out of everybody yeah so
but going back to so who's at the top
for you
it's tough because it's it's it's a
tough conversation to have because you
look uh julio chavez senior you know
who's like [ __ ] 90 and so whatever 90
and 40. that guy fought like every day
and the biggest gate live gate of all
time in mexico mexico city i think it
was like 120 000 sold out it's a profit
you know you look at sugar ray like it's
tough man we talk great as well fair so
let's say today top ten you put canelo
on top ten today it has canelo already
done yeah number one right now i don't
know no no no no no i don't even know if
i can name 10 boxers today oh oh no no
that's not what i'm asking i'm asking 10
bucks canelo amongst the history has
canelo done enough does he already have
enough in his catalogue to say he is an
arguably top 10 guy for sure really yeah
you already put look at the different
weight classes that he's competing at
yeah for sure yeah and there's the star
power
watching and fight i mean doing weight
is that good amazing it's really really
ridiculous but again you wanna see him
fight earl spence or terence crawford
different promoters so we're never going
to get by the way all i'm thinking of
right now is the scenic coming to
america it's like uh rocky maciana every
time you want to talk about joe lewis
you bring up rocky marciano right yeah
that's six they want yes they want
exactly that's rocky mountain joel
lewis's ass that's where i'm at with
this yeah it's put rocky on the list
listen mayweather wakes up and
mayweather says i'm the greatest of all
time it is an argument he's the only one
that's undefeated is there anyone else
who's completely undefeated yeah
marciano is the other one no who's
marcelo was 40 yeah
the difference is floyd once he got to
that level you're paying to watch him
lose and he's very defensive fighter he
was fighting off his back foot in super
defenses yeah like didn't knock and
didn't finish anybody but you know he
made it he said something he says
everybody keeps talking about i dodge
pacquiao i'm older than pacquiao yeah
you know he's like what are you dodging
the guy i'm older than the guy and i
agreed to he should have beaten me the
other way around pat here's your next
your next business venture and you're
gonna we're gonna partner with thick boy
studios here to make this happen
klitschko brothers did this thing where
you box one round and then you play
chess in the second round and you either
had to win by knockout or you had to do
a checkmate it's crazy thing out there
over there in the ukraine they got a lot
of time on their hands but we do the
same thing but you're going to box one
around and then you got to come out and
do a roast battle in the second round
that'd be fun so you do a roast battle
so you roast each other and then you
know you've got a box pete davis
wouldn't it work you know why it
wouldn't work have you seen that
the one audio clip of canelo that goes
viral have you seen the on tick tock the
camera call me a [ __ ]
some dogs
call me a [ __ ]
i have to say they came along
yeah so canelo because if you did a
roasting canelo is like his the ability
to roast yeah triple g's can be tough as
well yeah here's that big drama show
personality yeah
so that that that that business model is
out the window fairly quickly but well i
don't know there you go but the point is
boxing needs to figure it out there it
is we're pitching those ideas boxing to
do something canelo canelo brought
something up the other day canelo said
he said if mayweather were to fight me
at my peak versus his peak i'd crush him
that's what canelo said do you agree
with that i agree with yeah i'm agreeing
with canelo fans really huge so you
think canelo's peak beats mayweather
yeah yeah a prime canada yeah but canelo
is bigger than mayweather right they're
not the same weight class
they they they fought before and he beat
him but canelo is 21 years old so
floyd's oh they've fought before of
course but but canelo was 21 and didn't
have the experience and floyd was in his
prime so he got a young like
fresh out of the gym canelo and floyd
was prime floyd
he dominated do you think you think
floyd terry does
uh no i think he was just downloading
the data and trying to figure it out and
connor landed some good shots but he
never really felt like he was in danger
at all he could turn it off no he did
get hit and then he was like enough's
enough yeah and then went to work yeah
that's what i feel like you're saying
but i also felt like it was like a
little like gentleman's uh agreement i'm
not gonna put it on you the first couple
rounds here i i think he was smart and
cerebral about it was like all right
this we know the kid has a good left
hand it's sneaking it's coming from
angles we probably haven't seen in
boxing so and that's what made floyd
great like i'm gonna download the data
and then pick it apart so those first
few rounds he's downloading the data
connor landed some nothing too crazy and
then he just [ __ ] ate him alive now
logan paul on the other hand
logan paul you i worked that so i worked
both those fights
with floyd mayweather you know i'm in
the back so i'm doing the interview so
floyd i went to floyd's training room
and he sent mitts and i was that's the
first time ever in my life i went oh he
looks 46 or whatever he is 46 years old
he looks funny i was like oh my god gray
and his beard i'm like oh this like ken
mitch i'm like he looks older man i was
like logan might have a decent shot here
now i do think there was some sort of
agreement you know not to for him just
completely
knock his ass out because even you know
i when i say i was ringside i mean like
i'm on the [ __ ] ring sitting there
watching them and while you know they're
announcing and floyd's moving
logan kept saying it's an exhibition
champ remember it's exhibition champ can
you tell me what is [ __ ] like so you
think if floyd wanted to knock his ass
out he could have i don't know if he
could
i i don't know if he could he he
probably could dismantle him a little
sooner but there's no way
but the problem is you're dealing with
whatever he's four i think he's 40
you're dealing with a 46 year old man
who's
floyd's time have you had him in here
floyd's tiny dude logan's a big dude man
and he's hanging on he's just awkward
for floyd what do you mean this is
exhibition what's he trying to say
what's what's the messaging behind that
i just yeah i don't know
just
i think dude let's let's have some fun
you're like hey like let's have some fun
man you know that's like rocky three or
four when these other little followings
yeah remember it's just exhibition it's
just exhibition
but again i think you'd have to be crazy
to think that thing was all fluke and
floyd can knock him out in 30 seconds
because
so floyd's legacy to go six rounds with
this [ __ ] youtuber it's not a great
man he doesn't want that right trust me
if floyd wanted to get him out of there
in 30 seconds he would have done it man
that made him look great i agree this is
there's there's someone
there's precedent for this too though i
mean look you talked about ali look up
ali versus uh lyle alzado back in the
day lyle alzado
the reason everybody in the world thinks
steroids are bad
pounds you know yeah but he had cancer
with something else but they chalked it
up to steroids what he did he came on
like you know cbs was like i wish i i
never did these things
with the wwe murdered his family
committed suicide
his finishing move for people don't
remember crispin was he would jump off
the top rope and use his head to like
head back but i will tell you but i will
tell you this let's not get it twisted
you know how they say money makes you
more of what you are today if you give
when you're broke you're going to give a
lot when you're rich right sure if
you're stingy when you're broke you're
stingy when you're rich if you're a dick
when you're broke you're going to be a
rich dick is what you're going to be
right i'm going to be way better at it
so i think steroids makes you more of
what you are today like if you're saying
your brother's got a temper let's just
say if he gets on like we don't want
steroids no no we don't want him
like if we want him decade or something
like an old-school
we got any hecklers you'll see him go
through the crowd man yeah where's the
last time that you guys yeah yeah
thank god you wouldn't be able to handle
this wrestle like we'll mess around
wrestle with them [ __ ] around with them
but we haven't gotten like a real fight
since we were kids jay how tall are you
man
you're six two
when did he get bigger than you when did
that happen in college oh so you had a
good run you had a good run man
yeah i remember my dad used to bully me
too my dad was a big dude and i came
back like freshman year college and i'm
like what's up so i'm not so yeah
i beat him in an army oh you don't want
to leave for the first time when i was
18 and he was legitimately mad like
legitimately angry
yeah listen
i can see that question question for you
guys
so the product of sports nba football
all of that that we got going on right
now uh nhl you can fight it's part of
the game love it totally chilled you
want to fight go for it baseball used to
be able to do that too well baseball
still has a little bit of that which is
kind of cool right you know you like to
so like i will tell you if the highlight
shows up espn there is like a
pitcher hits the player you know there's
a brawl i'm gonna watch it three minutes
i'm watching that three-minute video
right bro the nba in the 90s that's what
i'm trying to get
let me tell you let me tell you
the knicks baby let me tell you what i'm
getting to let me let me tell you what
i'm getting to you think there is a
a business model for uh sports to say
look
here's what we're doing in the nba
you get into the nba we're creating a
new league called the fba okay fighting
basketball association whatever you want
to call it right you can call it mixed
martial arts whatever but then here's
the part like something happens
you can fight you go sit for 10 minutes
yeah you come back you got a timeout
cool and then you do that in in in the
nba yeah or maybe a little bit of the
nfl because back in the days if you
watch like you know what happened in
detroit pistons what happened with
lambeau barkley shack embarked on here's
the thing there was something about it
you got suspended yeah yeah i saw a
video the other day vernon maxwell runs
up to the 16 row hits a fan in the face
now obviously that's cross on the line
the guy got that's what the fan did but
you're also awesome yeah there's a part
of it that is right i would rather have
ron artest running up in tunes of the
palace than lebron going hey hey hey
they gotta go they said something really
mean yeah please kick them out no
you want fans getting knocked out by
players you wrote the check cash but
the last thing the nba wants is just
that's what that's fighting with fans
they could use the ratings i think so
they got to figure something out because
what they're doing now with this soy boy
like soft
movement man it's like not working
but all they're doing now and then nfl
did the same thing too they're
protecting their investments the tom
brady rules all that stuff you the the
the soy boy the woke i'm with you 100
they're in hollywood they're in
hollywood brother they're in hollywood i
don't have to deal with those woke boys
when i do sets outside that i'm i'm i'm
surrounded by more like minds like me
there's a ton of people like what's it
like working with those people they're
saying like
literally
but you got to realize what he said
earlier this is again the beautiful
thing about what's going on in the
marketplace right now the market can no
longer bully you to tell you what you
have to do no the market can no longer
force you like you know how the whole uh
casting couch whatever you know used to
be back in the days you don't need to go
through that no more that's the whole
market change but also now somebody says
you got to take this job no dude i don't
need to take this correct i'm good it's
changed i'm asking sports basketball
do you think there is
you know going to get to a point where
because you watched
regular season today the other day i
posted a comment i said you know if you
followed bleacher report espn
sportscenter uh if you followed any of
the laker highlights you would think
lakers are 36 and oh correct because
they only show lebron's best highlights
and then you go 117 to 102. lebron and
lakers are one and five the last six
games so they're only showing highlights
you watch the game it's the worst
fantasy game the only game i enjoy
watching today's uh steph curry only
game agree everything is exciting yeah
hey guys some breaking news betty white
just passed oh no way betty white she
didn't make it to 100 she was going to
be 100 in january
apparently the youngest guy here is
surprised so he's david you okay
that's brutal though to announce that a
actually full disclosure i thought john
madden passed years ago bro are you
being sarcastic i'm not even joking how
dare you bro
i haven't seen john madden live in
decades this was the wildest thing
that's ever happened truth when i found
out john madden died like i was sad and
my brain is telling me yeah my brain is
like bro you've never met this guy like
but my heart is like yeah he's mad in
the video games the boys yeah i felt
like my uncle passed away do you know
the magic story do you know the madden
story like how it happened when he first
signed like they're gonna say we're
gonna make a game after you i know i
know was like i get like he was like
kind of hesitant he was like yeah he's
going to be big and then [ __ ] so the
guy says hey buy the stocks okay we're
going to give you the opportunity to buy
the stocks he calls us the greatest
mistake of his lifetime he says buy the
stock and john's like i don't care about
buying the stock he says come do this
we're not going to pay you but i'm
telling you wow yeah so john's like no
i'm at a point right now i'm john madden
pay me up front
so john goes they use his name for the
game he just gets an upfront check and
then they leave and it blows up
and then it blows up he's like holy [ __ ]
i made a big mistake well here's
apartheid which the story ends with 14
years later 14 years later he goes and
sits down good for the sports guys on
what they did with them he said he says
listen you guys have been using my name
we got to make something work ea sports
says don't even worry about it we're
going to buy your naming rights you know
what they paid them for their naming
rights 100 million 150 million wow 150
million yeah so opposed to that tony
hawk has told this story where you know
tony hawk huge videos yeah
they made the game he has all his
friends in it before it releases the the
i don't know if he's ea sports but they
came to and said we think this game's
gonna be pretty good man we're just
gonna pay once and he goes i was broke
at that time they go we're gonna give
you 500 000 and he goes and that's like
life changing yeah like i was making no
money and he's like nah i think i'm just
going to take my chance and you'll give
me a share of the sales for each game
like well yeah but we'll just give you
like a million or 500 now and dude
you're rich he's like no i don't want
i'll take my chance good for him really
and then how much is he more him oh my
god hundreds of millions he's still
going man and his friends all make money
off of it too because they're in the
game they call it one of the greatest
games of all time yes the famous story
that goes in the other direction i'm
sure you guys all know is is forming
grill you know how that happened they
wanted to give the whole they went to
hulk hogan first but he went with the
energy training that's why he went with
the uh the uh the blender because he's
like a grilling doors this is stupid
who's ever gonna want to grill indoors
so he goes with the blender
and then they go to george foreman like
hey look you got to have this girl he's
like all right whatever put my name on
it now are they blaming covet for betty
white too or what are we doing here
no he's got the breaking news
american icon betty white has died just
weeks before milestone birthday tmz has
learned law enforcement thrilling nancy
very passed at her home just before 9 30
a.m a trailblazer and pioneer media
betty had the longest running career of
any woman on tv prior to her death
starring in multiple shows over the last
deck eight decades
eight decades starring
starting all the way back to 1939. by
the way thank you for being here lasting
i mean lasting power right there bro
betty is perhaps the most famous for a
lead role in the rondo arizona golden
girls which ran from 1985 1992 she's
been in tons of by the way have you seen
betty white's younger picture do you
know what you're looking she's a bad guy
can you put yourself you've been over 31
years old
yeah betty white david i'm sure you want
to do it anyways just type in young
betty white you know what's [ __ ] sex
in the city is just golden girls after
dark it's just like x-rays
it's [ __ ]
that's a young betty white beauty man
yeah that's true
good for her you know that she was the
face of the life settlement market
well she
insurance i do like something called
life settlements it's like reverse
insurance byron knew dale's favorite she
was yeah exactly she was the uh
the face of the lifestyle market for
years they paid her you know an upfront
deal
right and a million bucks or whatever
and great career though well rest in
peace betty white yeah
anybody that can last that long and
anything you got to give them respect
question do what do you think about the
way nfl is right now or the nba right
now is handling the covid situation
you know it's like suspended suspended i
like it i like that nfl did the thing
where you're if you're asymptomatic
they're not making you sit out from the
game i give them a little leeway because
when the the virus first came we didn't
know too much about it so everyone kind
of freaked out and i like that the nba
did the bubble you got to take your hat
off to dana white for do you know not
stopping they earned so many more fans
doing that where he's like i'm not
stopping this man pay setter yes so
um you know it's tough because at first
we didn't know what how how to deal with
this thing but now we know so they're
being a little more educated about it i
you know it made me a bigger
fan of aaron rodgers the way he he was
dealing with things and the cancel
culture came out of him i bought aaron
rodgers jersey because of it and uh you
know it's ridiculous man it's ridiculous
he's double down triple down man patty
mack he goes on that show and he lets it
fly now we were talking about that what
was it yesterday or this morning yeah
we're like do you think they're gonna
give him the mvp he's clearly the mvp of
the league you have to yeah they have to
he's he's made it so that they just
can't even they can he's on undeniable
you you give to him or give to uh coop
for the la rams
brady uh yeah oh yeah really yeah
oh you don't think braden is winning
this year no
brady was favored up until about three
games because aaron's playing dark
horses interceptions all season
two of the game four interceptions all
season we'll win it guaranteed yeah
rogers and brady by the way if he wins
it here's the best story if he wins it
oh my gosh if he wins it
and then he goes wins the super bowl
this season
that's a great story for that and nfl is
going to hate it if that's the favorite
player of all time if he does that who
aaron rodgers yours oh yeah if he does
that fair player just spits in the face
yeah just yeah big [ __ ] you love it the
moment he did what he did i bought his
best rookie card i said i support you
bro let's just get your best rookie card
i'm gonna put in the safe i hate the
packers i'm from denver but i bought his
[ __ ] jersey and worked for a week
and was hoping i'd show up to starbucks
in l.a with the soybeans hoping
somebody'd say something i was looking
for a skeleton is that something that
they do is that something that they do
they say something dude really oh if you
don't have a mask on la dude really
they'll come up and say something oh
dude outside no matter who you are stop
not walking outside yeah i'd be on my
bike because they're in the high to
cover and we're locked down yeah they
locked down the trails behind my house
the santa monica mountains i was in the
middle of i'm talking nowhere the
closest person's probably 50 miles and
people put a mask on we're in the
running outside
nuts
not now anymore you saw the lady on the
floor it's not like that right in
restaurants or if you go in the
starbucks jar of a mask on oh yeah okay
indoors indoors the yellow indoors
they'll do that
there's nobody worse than these
progressive comedians too though man
they won't say anything one-on-one but
once they get like a little bit of a
group around them and they get like
feeling a little bit tough too and
you're in the ground who are like the
big progressive comedian
i'm not gonna name
it you don't want those problems no so
but but i will i'll tell you i will tell
you one story though it's guys who can't
sell tickets yeah yeah and the um
there's a guy that you know that uh i'm
not gonna tell the story very very very
popular now but then he was great for a
long time but he wasn't really getting
booked because of how
kind of edgy he was and there was a
woman uh at a comedy club who ran she
was a booker and she took that job way
too damn seriously and she was like look
when you go on the night don't tell that
joke about trump this was years ago and
he goes you're telling me what jokes i
can and can't tell and she goes yeah if
you want if you ever want to play here
again you won't tell that joke about
trump he goes all right fine goes up
looks to the side tells the audience
goes so that that [ __ ] right there says
i can't tell a joke about trump what do
you guys think so he went nuts and he
went nuts and he brought the house down
he's very famous now yeah and he sounds
like a he's a new york guy yes yes yeah
so
he has a really good patreon
so anyway
so the
so anyway the um one time i was telling
the story though i will tell i'll just
be honest with it these progresses i'm
talking about i was at a club
and there's like three shows in a row
and you do your 10 minutes and you go
back to the green room then you do 10
minutes and i was still drinking at the
time and i was getting pretty you're
sober now
mostly so
i was drinking at the time i was
drinking it i was drinking heavy at the
time
and then uh so i'm a few whiskey's deep
and then we're three hours in and this
there just been some sort of shooting
and this girl is like pontificating
about white people and guns and this and
that and she's right yeah of course
and so finally normally i could just
keep my mouth shut and move it keep it
moving but today i was just like i can't
i was like bro let me ask you a question
what's a more likely scenario that i
would need a gun to kill you or that you
would need a gun to stop me and you
would have thought what i asked
everybody said did you just threaten to
kill her yeah how could you pop can't
and dude they made this whole big thing
i got kicked out of the club for life
that i threatened this girl i was like i
didn't threaten this girl all i tried to
do was explain to her that for like the
history of our species being big strong
and capable of violence was all you
needed to be successful because of the
rules that we have now and specifically
because of firearms people that are five
foot 100 pounds of just as much of a
voice as anybody else you should be the
biggest 2a advocate out of everybody
have you guys seen a change leaving
because you guys were in texas correct
and then coming to florida have you seen
the same
i'm from uh this is this is a lot more
chill even than texas yeah so
listen neither cat neither texas or
florida is even close to what l.a sure
you're in a whole different world in l.a
when you're the epicenter of it yeah
it's insane what's going on
i feel like i escaped the soviet union
bro yeah like i'm like this is paradise
we were on the boat yesterday man
there's still lockdowns in new york
right now there's still mandates yeah i
mean it's crazy but you got to know
what's happening here so here's what's
going on with
south florida
south florida miami the mayor credit to
him i mean the guy
he's a beast his father was a mayor now
he's a mayor
and if desantis runs a lot of people
would like to see him potentially end up
being the governor of florida who knows
if he's got that kind of inspiration he
should run for president yeah
he may do that he may do that where he's
at he may uh there's a level take that
route yeah now you can skip some levels
well here's what he did miami's become
the crypto capital u.s that's what
they're talking about so miami is now
the place where people are coming for
crypto uh new york was the financial
capital they may keep it that way
they're trying to make it here a lot of
guys are moving out here
texas ain't going away texas on a golf
score if you want to raise kids great
place to be if you like a little bit of
lifestyle you're more here so if
california and texas had a baby it'd be
florida south florida specifically south
florida yeah you get into water get the
lifestyle sold and you get the taxes the
tax benefits regulation no one bothers
you so
they just got to make sure they keep it
that way correct words out today by the
way did you hear who's the highest paid
government employee in america today oh
it's a fabulous voucher doctor himself
highest paid government employee his
pension alone
they just came out with his pension
alone what's his pension plan by the way
350 a year 350 a year fauci okay
uh he said he will not retire until the
pandemic is over i'm sure many people
are happy about that his retirement
package is shaping up to be the largest
federal retirement package in u.s
history
uh 350 thousand dollars uh our auditors
at openthebooks.com estimate dr fauci's
retirement would exceed 350
dollars this is what he's going to tell
you what if jake paul fights dr fauci
i'm on i'm team i'm team paul
all of a sudden you know what i i
wouldn't mind seeing let's let's get a
realistic fight i wouldn't mind seeing
rand paul fight foundation
that's what i would want would you pay
the watch
i'd pay to watch it
i don't know man rand paul is a seasoned
vet at this point his neighbor's been
trying to take him over by the way i
would put i'd put two million dollars
for the winner if ouchie and and ran
fast
they already know you've got five
million in the can but that's a
difference i don't actually just want to
see an actual verbal debate like what
they've done in uh yeah it's great when
they're together but can you imagine
those two guys fighting
it'd be obviously very value's the size
of without all the time
he's 80. 20 is 80 years old 81 81 i
think he's five six he's a sprightly 81
though but he says he was a basketball
star in high school how dare he just you
know again we're loose with the term
star exactly yeah
he claims they have a circle
that's why
that's when jews and italians were
running the nba in the 1930s who who's
the commissioner in the nba now
silver
i don't know how much has changed then
who people around the nba
stern silver what are you talking about
they're saying two jewish dudes jewish
jews yeah who's running the nba no but
who would you more than just the nba
i think so you know the whole time you
want to make it in hollywood shut your
face yeah you know that that's what they
told me years ago i'm still fighting
we're coming down to the end of it but
at the beginning i asked you guys a
question about uh you know what's sports
tougher right we're telling all the
players you know mlb nba all this other
stuff go to 90s okay 90s if nolan ryan
and michael jordan oh i love it
if noah wright and jordan find it who
takes it this jordan beats the [ __ ] out
of him
and ryan
michael
i know i'm with i love nolan ryan too
and i like what he stands for
we
the greatest athlete of all time is
michael jeffrey jordan style yeah and
he's saying so how how big is that nolan
ryan is way bigger than you guys think
[ __ ] are blind to do that yeah
you know ryan's a big dude nolan ryan is
a big dude but michael jordan is a
sociopath dude throws a hundred and ten
miles an hour you don't think he could
throw a hoof first of all
pictures
kobe said kobe said i had big hands but
not the biggest i was quick but not the
quickest i was fast but not the fastest
i could jump but i couldn't jump the
highest right
all of those things he said
michael would replace a sentence like
this i had the biggest hat i had the
fastest first step i was the quickest
and i jumped the highest
narcissist your ass right the ultimate
narcissist
dude you bring it back to the back in
the day the american gladiators and
stuff there was video game uh monster
league like all that nitro yeah dude i
know that this is a joke and we're like
super you know manly on today's podcast
but i do you talk about channeling yes
manly yeah manly around here goddammit
[ __ ] dude but the uh
in 20 years man
do you think there's even freaking
contact sports
yes gerard honestly nfl's going
somewhere do you think you have these
guys you think you're going to be able
to touch the quarterback in 20 years do
you think you're actually going to be
able to to sack the quarterback in 20
years yes that's kind of hold the whole
point of the freaking game dude
what do you think like ufc you think
it's happening 20 years from now they're
going to be running around and fighting
always ballerina dresses
are there a lot of kids out there
playing tackle football in the streets
anymore they're a lot of kid like when
we were growing up you can you can go
down any block you can see kids riding
their bikes bicycles on the side of the
street and then people playing tackle
football
on the pavement when was the last
[ __ ] are you doing what was it that's
what i'm talking about i would i'm
thinking we would play in the [ __ ]
grass yeah well you're also soy boys
yeah dude we played tackle football on
the grass there's no skin on anybody's
knees up there bing bong so what i'm
talking about
bro
when was the last time you even saw kids
riding their bikes anywhere man that's
what i'm saying i know i sound like i
see games of my kids bro i see gangs of
white kids first doing their tricks
neither one of you guys have kids yeah
kids ride bikes yeah
all the time yeah kids ride bikes so i
don't know
but i'm with you brandon this was a
blast my man really enjoyed
yeah thank you thank you everybody bye
bye bye bye
you